good morning everyone thank you for
thank you all for joining us
this is MIT six s-191 and we'd like to
welcome to welcome you to this course on
introduction to deep learning so in this
course you'll learn how to build
remarkable algorithms intelligent
algorithms capable of solving very
complex problems that just a decade ago
were not even feasible to solve and
let's just start with this notion of
intelligence so at a very high level
intelligence is the ability to process
information so that it can be used to
inform future predictions and decisions
now when this intelligence is not
engineered but rather a biological
inspiration such as in humans it's
called human intelligence but when it's
engineered we refer to it as artificial
intelligence so this course is a course
on deep learning which is just a subset
of artificial intelligence and really
it's just a subset of machine learning
which involves more traditional methods
where we tried to learn representations
directly from data and we'll talk about
this more in detail later today but let
me first just start by talking about
some of the amazing successes that deep
learning has had in the past so in 2012
this competition called imagenet came
out which tasked AI researchers to build
an AI system capable of recognizing
images objects in images and there was
millions of examples in this data set
and the winner in 2012 for the first
time ever was a deep learning based
system and a when it came out it
absolutely shattered all other
competitors and crushed the competition
across the country crush the challenge
and today these deep learning based
systems have actually surpassed human
level accuracy on the image net
challenge and can actually recognize
images even better than humans can now
in this class you'll actually learn how
to build complex vision systems building
a computer that
how to see and just tomorrow you'll
learn how to build an algorithm that
will take as input x-ray images and as
output it will detect if that person has
a pneumothorax just from that single
input image you'll even make the network
explain to you why it decided to
diagnose the way it diagnosed by looking
inside the network and understanding
exactly why I made that decision deep
neural networks can also be used to
model sequences where your data points
are not just single images but rather
temporally dependent so for this you can
think of things like predicting the
stock price translating sentences from
English to Spanish or even generating
new music so actually today you'll learn
how to create and actually you'll create
yourselves an algorithm that learns that
first listens to hours of music learns
the underlying representation of the
notes that are being played in those
songs and then learns to build brand new
songs that have never been heard before
and there are really so many other
incredible success stories of deep
learning that I could talk for many
hours about and will try to cover as
many of these as possible as part of
this course but I just wanted to give
you an overview of some of the amazing
ones that we'll be covering as part of
the labs that you'll be implementing and
that's really the goal of what we want
you to accomplish as part of this class
firstly we want to provide you with the
foundation to do deep learn to
understand what these algorithms are
doing underneath the hood how they work
and why they work we will provide you
some of the practical skills to
implement these algorithms and deploy
them on your own machines and will talk
to you about some of the stating state
of art and cutting edge research that's
happening in deep learning industries
and deep learning academia institutions
finally the main purpose of this course
is we want to build a community here at
MIT that is devoted to advancing the
state of artificial intelligence
advancing a state of deep learning as
part of this course we'll cover some of
the limitations of these algorithms
there are many
we need to be mindful of these
limitations so that we as a community
can move forward and create more
intelligent systems but before we do
that let's just start with some
administrative details in this course so
this course is a one-week course today
is the first lecture we meet every day
this week 10:30 a.m. to 1:30 p.m. and
this during this three hour time slot
were broken down into one and a half
hour time slots around 50% of the course
see each and each of those have half
sections of this course will consist of
lectures which is what you're in right
now and the second part is the labs
where you'll actually get practice
implementing what you learn in lectures
we have an amazing set of lectures lined
up for you
so today we're going to be talking about
some of the introduction to neural
networks which is really the backbone of
deep learning we're also talking about
modeling sequence data so this is what I
was mentioning about the temporally
dependent data tomorrow we'll talk about
computer vision and deep generative
models we have one of the inventors of
generative adversarial networks coming
to give that lecture for us so that's
going to be a great lecture and the day
after that we'll touch on deep
reinforcement learning and some of the
open challenges in AI and how we can
move forward past this course we'll
spend the final two days of this course
talking or hearing from some of the
leading industry representatives doing
deep learning in their respective
companies and these are bound to be
extremely interesting or extremely
exciting so I highly recommend attending
these as well for those of you who are
taking this course for credit you have
two options to fulfill your graders
assignment the first option is a project
proposal it's a one-minute project pitch
that will take place during Friday and
for this you have to work in groups of
three or four and what you'll be tasked
to do is just come up with interesting
deep learning idea and try to show some
sort of results if possible
we understand that one week is extremely
short to create any type of results or
even come up with a interesting idea for
that matter but we're going to be giving
out some amazing prizes so including
some nvidia gpus and google homes on
friday you'll like I said give a
one-minute pitch there's somewhat of an
arts to your idea in just one minute
even though it's extremely short so we
will be holding you to a strict deadline
of that one minute
the second option is a little more
boring but you'll be able to write a
one-page paper about any deep learning
paper that you find interesting and
really that's if you can't do the
project proposal you can do that this
class has a lot of online resources you
can find support on Piazza please post
if you have any questions about the
lectures the labs installing any of the
software etc also try to keep up to date
with the course website we'll be posting
all of the lectures labs and video
recordings online as well we have an
amazing team that you can reach out to
at any time in case you have any
problems with anything feel free to
reach out to any of us and we wanted to
give a huge thanks to all of our
sponsors who without this without their
support this class would simply not
happened the way the way it's happening
this year so now let's start with the
fun stuff and let's start by actually
asking ourselves a question why do we
even care about deep learning so why now
and why do we why do we even sit in this
class today so traditional machine
learning algorithms typically define
sets of pre-programmed features and the
data and they work to extract these
features as part of their pipeline now
the key differentiating point of deep
learning is that it recognizes that in
many practical situations these features
can be extremely brittle so what deep
learning tries to do is learn these
features directly from data as opposed
to being hand engineered
by the human that is can we learn if we
want to learn to detect faces can we
first learn automatically from data that
to detect faces we first need to detect
edges in the image compose these edges
together to detect eyes and ears then
compose these eyes and ears together to
form higher-level facial structure and
in this way deep learning represents a
form of a hierarchical model capable of
representing different levels of
abstraction in the data so actually the
fundamental building blocks of deep
learning which are neural networks have
actually been existing have actually
existed for decades so why are we
studying this now well there's three key
points here the first is that data has
become much more pervasive we're living
in a big data environment these
algorithms are hungry for more and more
data and accessing that data has become
easier than ever before
second these algorithms are massively
parallel Liza below and can benefit
tremendously from modern GPU
architectures that simply just did not
exist just less more than a decade ago
and finally due to open-source tool
boxes like tensor flow building and
deploying these algorithms has become so
streamlined so simple that we can teach
it in a one-week course like this and
it's become extremely deployable for the
massive public so let's start with now
looking at the fundamental building
block of deep learning and that's the
perceptron this is really just a single
neuron in a neural network so the idea
of a perceptron or a single neuron is
extremely simple let's start by talking
about the forward propagation of
information through this data unit we
define a set of inputs x1 through XM on
the left and all we do is we multiply
each of these inputs by their
corresponding weight theta1 through
theta m which are those arrows we take
this weighted we take this weighted
combination
of all of our inputs sum them up and
pass them through a nonlinear activation
function and that produces our output
why it's that simple so we have M inputs
one output number and you can see it
summarized on the right-hand side as a
mathematic single mathematical equation
but actually I left that one important
detail that makes the previous slide not
exactly correct
so I left that this notion of a bias a
bias is a that green term you see on the
left and this just represents some way
that we can allow our model to learn or
we can allow our activation function to
shift to the left or right
so it allows if we provide allows us to
when we have no input features to still
provide a positive output so on this
equation on the right we can actually
rewrite this using linear algebra and
dot products to make this a lot cleaner
so let's do that let's say X capital X
is a vector containing all of our inputs
x1 through XM capital theta is now just
a vector containing all of our Thetas
theta 1 to theta M we can rewrite that
equation that we had before is just
applying a dot product between X and
theta adding our bias theta 0 and apply
our non-linearity G now you might be
wondering since I've mentioned this a
couple times now what is this nonlinear
function G well I said it's the
activation function but let's see an
example of what in practice G actually
could be so one very popular activation
function is the sigmoid function you can
see a plot of it here on the bottom
right and this is a function that takes
its input any real number on the x-axis
and transforms it to an output between 0
and 1 because all outputs of this
function are between 0 & 1 it makes it a
very popular choice in deep learning to
represent probabilities in fact there
are many types of nonlinear activation
functions in
Durrell networks and here are some of
the common ones throughout this
presentation you'll also see tensorflow
code snippets like the ones you see on
the bottom here since we'll be using
tensorflow for our labs and well this is
some way that I can provide to you to
kind of link the material in our
lectures with what you'll be
implementing in labs so the sigmoid
activation function which I talked about
in the previous slide now on the left is
it's just a function like I said it's
commonly used to produce probability
outputs each of these activation
functions has their own advantages and
disadvantages on the right a very common
activation function is the rectified
linear unit or Lu this function is very
popular because it's extremely simple to
compute it's piecewise linear it's zero
before with inputs less than zero it's X
with any input greater than zero and the
gradients are just zero or one with a
single non-linearity at the origin and
you might be wondering why we even need
activation functions why can't we just
take our dot product at our bias and
that's our output why do we need the
activation function activation functions
introduce nonlinearities into the
network that's the whole point of why
activations themselves are nonlinear we
want to model nonlinear data in the
world because the world is extremely
nonlinear but suppose I gave you this
this plot green and red points and I
asked you to draw a single line not a
curve just a line between the green and
red points to separate them perfectly
you'd find this really difficult and
probably you could get as best as
something like this now if your
activation function in your deep neural
network was linear since you're just
composing linear functions with linear
functions your output will always be
linear so the most complicated deep
neural network no matter how big or how
deep if the activation function is
linear your output can only look like
this but once we introduce
nonlinearities our network is extremely
more as the capacity of our network has
extremely increased we're now able to
model much more complex functions we're
able to draw decision boundaries that
were not possible with only linear
activation
options let's understand this with a
very simple example imagine I gave you a
train to network like the one we saw
before sorry a trained perceptron not in
network yet just a single node and the
weights are on the top right so theta 0
is 1 and the theta vector is 3 and
negative 2 the network has two inputs X
1 and X 2 and if we want to get the
output all we have to do is apply the
same story as before so we apply the dot
product of X and theta we add the bias
and apply our non-linearity but let's
take a look at what's actually inside
before we apply that non-linearity this
looks a lot like just a 2d line because
we have two inputs and it is we can
actually plot this line when it equals
zero in feature space so this is space
where I'm plotting x1 one of our
features on the x-axis and x2 the other
feature on the y-axis we plot that line
it's just the decision boundary
separating our entire space into two
subspaces now if I give you a new point
negative 1/2 and plot it on the sub in
this feature space depending on which
side of the line it falls on I can
automatically determine whether our
output is less than 0 or greater than 0
since our line represents a decision
boundary equal to 0 now we can follow
the math on the bottom and see that
computing the inside of this activation
function we get 1 minus 3 minus 2 sorry
minus 4 and we get minus 6 at the output
before we apply the activation function
once we apply the activation function we
get zero point zero zero two so negative
what was applied to the activation
function is negative because we fell on
the negative piece of this subspace well
if we remember with the sigmoid function
it actually divides our space into two
parts greater than 0.5 and less than 0.5
since we're modeling probabilities and
everything is between 0 & 1 so actually
our decision boundary where the input to
our network equals 0 sorry the side the
input to our activation function equals
0 corresponds to
the output of our activation function
being greater than or less than 0.5 so
now that we have an idea of what a
perceptron is let's just start now by
understanding how we can compose these
perceptrons together to actually build
neural networks and let's see how this
all comes together so let's revisit our
previous diagram of the perceptron now
if there's a few things that you learned
from this class let this be one of them
and we'll keep repeating it over and
over in deep learning you do a dot
product you apply a bias and you add
your non-linearity you keep repeating
that many many times three each node
each neuron and your neural network and
that's a neural network so it's simplify
this diagram a little I remove the bias
since we were going to always have that
and we just take you for granted from
now on I'll remove all of the weight
labels for simplicity and note that Z is
just the input to our activation
function so that's just the dot product
plus our bias if we want the output of
the network Y we simply take Z and we
apply our non-linearity like before if
we want to define a multi output
perceptron it's very simple we just add
another perceptron now we have two
outputs y1 and y2
each one has weight matrices it has
weight vector theta corresponding to the
weight of each of the inputs now let's
suppose we want to go the next step
deeper we want to create now a single
layered neural network single layered
neural networks are actually not deep
networks yet they're only there's still
shallow networks they're only one layer
deep but let's look at the singledom
layered neural network where now all we
do is we have one hidden layer between
our inputs and outputs we call this a
hidden layer because it's states are not
directly observable they're not directly
enforced by by the AI designer we only
enforce the inputs and outputs typically
the states in the middle are hidden and
since we now have a transformer
to go from our input space to our hidden
hidden lair space and from our hidden
lair space to our output layer space we
actually need two weight matrices theta
1 and theta 2 corresponding to the
weight matrices of each layer now if we
look at just a single unit in that
hidden layer it's the exact same story
as before it's one perceptron we take
its top product with all of the X's that
came before it and we apply I'm sorry we
take the dot product of the X's that
came before with the weight matrices
theta is theta one in this case we apply
a bias to get Z 2 and if we look we're
to look at a different hidden unit let's
say Z 3 instead we would just take
different weight matrices different our
dot product to change our bias would
change but and this means that Z would
change which means this activation would
also be different so from now on I'm
going to use this symbol to denote what
is called as a fully connected layer and
that's what we've been talking about so
far so that's every node and one layer
is connected to every node and another
layer by these weight matrices and this
is really just for simplicity so I don't
have to keep redrawing those lines now
if we want to create a deep neural
network all we do is keep stacking these
layers and fully connected weights
between the layers it's that simple but
the underlying building block is that
single perceptron set single dot product
non-linearity and bias that's it
so this is really incredible because
something so simple at the foundation is
still able to create such incredible
algorithms and now let's see an example
of how we can actually apply neural
networks to a very important question
that I know you are all extremely
worried about you care a lot about
here's the question you want to build an
AI system that answers the following
question will I pass this class yes or
no one or zero is the output to do this
let's start by defining a simple two
feature model one feature is the number
of lectures that you attend the second
feature is the number of hours that you
spend on your final project let's plot
this data in our feature space
reply Greenpoint's are people who pass
red points are people I fail we want to
know given a new person this guy he
spent ersity they spent five hours on
their final project and we went to four
lectures we want to know did that person
pass or failed a class and we want to
build a neural network that will
determine this so let's do it we have
two inputs one is for the others five we
have one hidden layer with three units
and we want to see the final output
probability of passing this class and we
computed as 0.1 or 10% well that's
really bad news because actually this
person did pass the class they passed it
with probability one now can anyone tell
me why the neural network got this such
so wrong why I do this yeah it is
exactly so this network has never been
trained it's never seen any data it's
basically like a baby it's never learned
anything so we can't expect it to solve
a problem and knows nothing about so to
do this to tackle this problem of
training a neural network we have to
first define a couple of things so first
we'll talk about the loss the loss of a
network basically tells our algorithm or
our model how wrong our predictions are
from the ground truth so you can think
of this as a distance between our
predicted output and our actual output
if the two are very close if we predict
something that is very close to the true
output our loss is very low if we
predict something that is very far in a
high-level sense far like in distance
then our loss is very high and we want
to minimize this from happening as much
as possible now let's assume we're not
given just one data point one student
but we're given a whole class of
students so as previous data I used this
entire class from last year and if we
want to quantify what's called the
empirical loss
now we care about how the model did on
average over the entire data set not for
just a single student but across the
entire data set and how we do that is
very simple we just take the average of
the loss of each data point if we have n
students it's the
average over end data points this has
other names besides empirical law
sometimes people call it the objective
function the cost function etc all of
these terms are completely the same
thing now if we look at the problem of
binary classification predicting if you
pass or fail this class yes or no 1 or 0
we can actually use something that's
called the softmax cross entropy loss
now for those of you who aren't familiar
with cross entropy or entropy this is a
extremely powerful notion that was
actually developed or first introduced
here at MIT over 50 years ago by Claude
Shannon and his master's thesis like I
said this was 50 years ago it's huge in
the field of signal processing
thermodynamics really all over computer
science that seen in information theory
now instead of predicting a single one
or zero output yes or no let's suppose
we want to predict a continuous valued
function not will I pass this class but
what's the grade that I will get and
then as a percentage let's say 0 to 100
now we're no longer limited to 0 to 1
but can't actually output any real
number on the number line now instead of
using cross entropy we might want to use
a different loss and for this let's
think of something like a mean squared
error loss whereas your predicted and
your true output diverged from each
other the loss increases as a quadratic
function ok great so now let's put this
new loss information to the test and
actually learn how we can train a neural
network by quantifying its loss and
really if we go back to what the loss is
at the very high level the loss tells us
how the network is performing right that
loss tells us the accuracy of the
network on a set of examples and what we
want to do is basically minimize the
loss over our entire training set really
we want to find the set of parameters
theta such that that loss J of theta
that's our empirical loss is minimum so
remember J of theta takes as input theta
and theta is just our weight
so these are the things that actually
define our network remember that the
loss is just a function of these weights
if we want to think about the process of
training we can imagine this landscape
so if we only have two weights we can
plot this nice diagram like this theta
zero and theta one are our two weights
they're on the four they're on the
planar axis on the bottom J of theta
zero and theta one are plotted on the z
axis what we want to do is basically
find the minimum of this loss of this
landscape if we can find the minimum
then this tells us where our loss is the
smallest and this tells us where theta
want with where or what values of theta
zero and theta one we can use to attain
that minimum loss so how do we do this
well we start with a random guess we
pick a point theta zero theta one and we
start there we compute the gradient of
this point on the lost landscape that's
DJ D theta
it's how the loss is changing with
respect to each of the weights now this
gradient tells us the direction of
highest ascent not descent so this is
telling us the direction going towards
the top of the mountain so let's take a
small step in the opposite direction so
we negate our gradient and we adjust our
weight such that we step in the opposite
direction of that gradient such that we
move continuously towards the lowest
point in this landscape until we finally
converge at a local minima and then we
just stop so let's summarize this with
some pseudocode so we randomly
initialize our weights we loop until
convergence the following we compute the
gradient at that point and simply we
apply this update rule where the update
takes as input the negative gradient now
let's look at this term here this is the
gradient like I said it explains how the
lost changes with respect to each weight
in the network but I never actually told
you how to compute this
this is actually a big big issue in
neural networks I just kind of took it
for granted so now let's talk about this
process of actually computing this
gradient because it's not that gradient
you kind of helpless
you have no idea which way down is you
don't know where to go in your landscape
so let's consider a very simple neural
network probably the simplest neural
network in the world it contains one
hidden unit one hidden layer and one
output unit and we want to compute the
gradient of our loss J of theta with
respect to theta to just data to for now
so this tells us how a small change in
theta 2 will impact our final loss at
the output so let's write this out as a
derivative we can start by just applying
a chain rule because J of theta is
dependent on Y right so first we want to
back propagate through Y our output all
the way back to theta 2 we can do this
because Y our output Y is only dependent
on the input and theta 2 that's it so
we're able to just from that perceptron
equation that we wrote on the previous
slide compute a closed-form gradient or
closed form derivative of that function
now let's suppose I change theta to 2
theta 1 and I want to compute the same
thing but now for the previous layer and
the previous weight all we need to do is
apply the chain rule one more time back
propagate those gradients that we
previously computed one layer further
it's the same story again we can do this
for the same reason this is because z1
our hidden state is only dependent on
our previous input X and that single
weight theta one now the process of back
propagation is basically you repeat this
process over and over again for every
way in your network until you compute
that gradient DJ D theta and you can use
that as part of your optimization
process
to find your local minimum now in theory
that sounds pretty simple I hope I mean
we just talked about some basic chain
rules but let's actually touch on some
insights on training these networks and
computing back propagation in practice
now the picture I showed you before is
not really accurate for modern deep
neural network architectures modern deep
neural network architectures are
extremely non convex this is an
illustration or a visualization of the
landscape like I've plotted before but
of a real deep neural network of ResNet
50 to be precise this was actually taken
from a paper published about a month ago
where the authors attempt to visualize
the lost landscape to show how difficult
gradient descent can actually be so
there's a possibility that you can get
lost in any one of these local minima
there's no guarantee that you'll
actually find a true global minimum so
let's recall that update equation that
we defined during gradient descent let's
take a look at this term here this is
the learning rate I didn't talk too much
about it but this basically determines
how large of a step we take in the
direction of our gradient and in
practice setting this learning rate it's
just a number but setting it can be very
difficult if we set the learning rate
too low then the model may get stuck in
a local minima and may never actually
find its way out of that local minima
because at the bottom a local minima
obviously your gradient is 0 so it's
just going to stop moving if I set the
learning rate to large it could
overshoot and actually diverge our model
could blow up ok ideally we want to use
learning rates that are large enough to
avoid local minima but also still
converge to our global minima so they
can overshoot just enough to avoid some
local local minima but then converge to
our global minima now how can we
actually set the learning rate well one
idea is let's just try a lot of
different things and see what works best
but I don't really like the solution
let's try and see if we can be a little
smarter than that how about we tried to
build an adaptive algorithm that changes
its learning rate
as training happens so this is a
learning rate that actually adapts to
the landscape that it's in so the
learning rate is no longer a fixed
number it can change it can go up and
down and this will change depending on
the location that that the update is
currently at the gradient in that
location may be how fast were learning
and many other many other possible
situations in fact this process of
optimization in in deep neural networks
and non convex situation has been
extremely explored there's many many
many algorithms for computing adaptive
learning rates and here are some
examples that we encourage you to try
out during your labs to see what works
best and for your problems especially
real-world problems things can change a
lot depending on what you learn in
lecture and what really works in lab and
we encourage you to just experiment get
some intuition about each of these
learning rates and really understand
them at a higher level so I want to
continue this talk and really talk about
more of the practice of deep neural
networks this incredibly powerful notion
of mini batching and I'll focus for now
if we go back to this gradient descent
algorithm this is the same one that we
saw before and let's look at this term
again so we found out how to compute
this term using back propagation but
actually what I didn't tell you is that
the computation here is extremely calm
is extremely expensive we have a lot of
data points potentially in our data set
and this takes as input a summation over
all of those data points so if our data
set is millions of examples large which
is not that large and the realm of
today's deep neural networks but this
can be extremely expensive just for one
iteration so we can compute this on
every iteration instead let's create a
variant of this algorithm called
stochastic gradient descent where we
compute the gradient just using a single
training example now this is nice
because it's really easy to compute the
gradient for a single training example
it's not nearly as intense as over the
entire training set but as the name
might suggest this is a more stochastic
estimate it's much more noisy it can
make us jump around the landscape in
ways that we didn't anticipate doesn't
actually represent the true gradient of
our data set because it's only a single
point so what's the middle ground how
about we define a mini batch of B data
points compute the average gradient
across those B data points and actually
use that as an estimate of our true
gradient now this is much faster than
computing the estimate over the entire
batch because B is usually something
like 10 to 100 and it's much more
accurate than SGD because we're not
taking a single example but we're
learning over a smaller batch a larger
batch sorry now the more accurate our
gradient estimation is that means the
more or the easier it will be for us to
converge to the solution faster means
will converge smoother because we'll
actually follow the true landscape that
exists it also means that we can
increase our learning rate to trust each
update more this also allows for
massively parallel Liza become petition
if we split up batches on different
workers on different GPUs or different
threads we can achieve even higher speed
ups because each thread can handle its
own batch then they can come back
together and aggregate together to
basically create that single learning
rate or completely complete that single
training iteration now finally the last
topic I want to talk about is that of
overfitting and regularization really
this is a problem of generalization
which is one of the most fundamental
problems in all of artificial
intelligence not just deep learning but
all of artificial intelligence and for
those of you who aren't familiar let me
just go over in a high level what
overfitting is what it means to
generalize ideally in machine learning
we want a model that accurately
describes our test data not our training
data but our test data said differently
we want to build models that can learn
representations from our training data
still generalized well on unseen test
data assume we want to build a line to
describe these points under fitting
describes the process on the left where
the complexity of our model is simply
not high enough to capture the nuances
of our data if we go to overfitting on
the right we're actually having to
complex of a model and actually just
memorizing our training data which means
that if we introduce a new test data
point it's not going to generalize well
ideally what we want to something in the
middle which is not too complex to
memorize all the training data but still
contains the capacity to learn some of
these nuances in this in the test set so
address to address this problem let's
talk about this technique called
regularization now regularization is
just this way that you can discourage
your models from becoming too complex
and absolutely as we've seen before this
is extremely critical because we don't
want our data we don't want our models
to just memorize data and only do well
in our training set one of the most
popular techniques for regularization in
neural networks is dropout this is an
extremely simple idea let's revisit this
picture of a deep neural network and
then drop out all we do during training
on every iteration we randomly drop some
proportion of the hidden neurons with
some probability P so let's suppose P
equals 0.5 that means we dropped 50% of
those neurons like that those
activations become zero and effectively
they're no longer part of our network
this forces the network to not rely on
any single node but actually find
alternative paths through the network
and not put too much weight on any
single example with any single single
node so it discourages memorization
essentially on every iteration we
randomly drop another 50% of the node so
on this iteration I may drop these on
the next iteration I may drop those and
since it's different on every iteration
you're encouraging the network to find
these different paths to its answer
the second technique for regularization
that we'll talk about is this notion of
early stopping now we know that the
definition of overfitting actually is
just when our model starts to perform
worse and worse on our test data set so
let's use that to our advantage to
create this early stopping algorithm if
we set aside some of our training data
and use it only as test data we don't
train with that data we can use it to
basically monitor the progress of our
model on unseen data so we can plot this
curve we're on the x axis we have the
training iterations on the y axis we
have the loss now they start off going
down together this is great because it
means that we're learning we're training
right that's great there comes a point
though where the testing data where the
testing data set and the add the loss
for that data set starts to Plateau now
if we look a little further the training
data set loss will always continue to go
down as long as our model has the
capacity to learn and memorize some of
that data but that doesn't mean that
it's actually generalizing well because
we can see that the testing data set has
actually started to increase this
pattern continues for the rest of
training but I want to focus on this
point here this is the point where you
need to stop training because after this
point you are overfitting and your model
is no longer performing well on unseen
data if you stop before that point
you're actually under fitting and you're
not utilizing the full potential the
full capacity of your network so I'll
conclude this lecture by summarizing
three key points that we've covered so
far first we've learned about the
fundamental building blocks of neural
networks called the perceptron we've
learned about stacking these units these
perceptrons together to compose very
complex hierarchical models and we've
learned how to mathematically optimize
these models using a process called back
row back propagation and gradient
descent finally we adjust some of the
practical challenges of training these
models in real life that you'll find
useful for the labs today
such as using adaptive learning rates
batching and regularization to combat
overfitting thank you and I'd be happy
to answer any questions now otherwise
we'll have Ferrini
talk to us about some of the deep
sequence models for modeling temporal
data